hello and welcome to see airplane food
yum from Ireland I guess yeah we get
some touch defense that's the stone wall
okay do I have anything good against the
stall wall to a play actually let's play
some something conventional here would
be three and so on I think this plan can
be answered with some p5 and based
setups but okay didn't happen just get
this traded at black probably will play
some c5 in the nearest future ok not yet
I just still have a couple of routine
moves here we go
prevent severe form yeah the hanging
pawns and some pretty typical hanging
porn situation there ok I think I'll
take he might play Knight takes Knight
okay night eggs I can also move my deep
empty two night so he takes with the
pawn let's see what now maybe here
asking about the a pawn and making night
c4 I actually could have played night c4
when then 95 hmm
hmm anyway this is also interesting ok
so if I take this you will take with the
deep on maybe because he feels that
nightie firefish and is interesting then
maybe
maybe I still should have taken first
them
the way it was I was happy that he had
to weaken the position a little bit now
to find me Knight g4 may be coming hmm
i'm not quite sure here in this position
what I'm doing to be honest looks a
little bit strange I don't have a very
clearly defined plan idea of 95 swipe in
93-94 okay let's let's see if I can put
some pressure now on the sea porn
he cannot go d4 I guess that would put a
now some check on c4 not sure how bad is
this but d4 is a very very tough
decision
yeah i'm not sure if 93 is really an
idea then it's got a couple of got
technical replies to that like c4d form
but we'll see what blacks move is first
so in case i can also just go nite d3
and night f4 yes you fall it's
interesting now the idea is that he has
like beat eggs d takes root takes some
92
okay c4 looks like you all this one yeah
this is also something that definitely
um it could have been considered okay if
I take now there is not G
yeah crabbing here
not entirely happy but what can you do
here 95 I think I'd be seven is ok
shouldn't be a big problem at least
okay so I'm taking him through takes
Bishop g2
I didn't think about that move at all
can I go here it seems to be
I don't see the blood King g2 is a fog
Queen 84 I guess well create one
yeah um I can take right okay too
black forfeits on time yeah it's always
that who maybe there's something but
doesn't seem to be yeah I didn't really
have a clear plan in this game I have to
admit after getting to this position I
think black is just okay I mean I was
hoping to have some play on the hanging
pawns but black is very active and
didn't feel particularly threatening
maybe he I should have taken and try to
figure this out I saw that and then I
saw like this and this and hmm hmm it's
not exactly great I would need like one
or two tempe like this and this if I I'm
sorry night c4 it would be okay but not
not like this yeah so I was continuing
with the shuffling policy not sure I'm
in here that look took quite okay i
actually have 97 here set of 93 i was
thinking of 93 all the time and this is
why i played it but i can just do this
and then grab stuff hmm badly played
okay now he went deform c4 was also
interesting but here i can take take and
go here then c 3 mmm Bishop g2 very
tough and unclear position how did the
dead end d4k i took this in 95 computer
wants to prep here
and now trade everything down and rope
26 so maybe a little something 0.6
pointing to the comp this is what you
did I took this okay so the computer
once a check King each one Queen and
there is no no threat at the moment I
have Bishop g2 okay sorry there's not
you one but it's something that it's not
not decisive this is what the engine is
giving interestingly enough check
there's a check here as reussi six Wow
check another engine slide still many
ways to get a very murky position okay
this and now it doesn't seem to work it
really really didn't it didn't work okay
it was a tough game i really didn't have
a PF a plan in this disposition the
hanging pots on positions with f5 being
played out very difficult and I never
studied them in any in any detail okay
thanks for watching